من العلا في السعوديه ناقش بين نادين
المشاهدات يا نادين في ارض العجائب اهلا
بك منوره العلا والسعوديه
يسعد هالصباح يا سهام واهلا بمشاهدي صباح
العربيه اينما كنتم عم تتابعونا اليوم
صباح العربيه تلطس استثنائيه نحن متواجدون
في العلا الساعه الان 8:00 صباحا يا سهام
الحراره برد برد برد كثير يعني هاي كمان
عشان اخبركم ولكن زفت اللقاء بيننا وبينكم
وبين كل المشاهدين ومن يتابعنا الان هو
الاهم سهام نحنا تجولنا في اكثر من منطقه
في العلا وسنكون ايضا في مناطق اخرى في
الايام المقبله لعرض الكثير والكثير من
التقارير وبالتالي سنبدا في صباح العربيه
للحديث عن المناطق التي زرناها وبالحديث
عن بلاد العجائب كما ذكرت هي سهام نشير
بانه لحظه وصولنا سمعنا هذا الخبر المفرح
بانه تم تصنيف العلا العلا
بارض العجائب العجائب الدنيا السبعه لعام
20 23 هذا التصنيف تزامن ايضا مع تصنيف
البلده القديمه في العلا من اجمل الق
سياحيه العالميه لعام 20 22 بالنسبه لهذا
التصنيف رحنا زرنا احد المواقع الذي يعتبر
من العجائب سنتحدث عنه وسنشاهد التقرير
بعد قليل يا سهام طيب نادين انت مش اول
مره تروحي للعلا للناس لما راحوا للعلا شو
تقولي لهم عنها شو هي ابرز مشاهداتك شو
اللي يميز العوله حتى تصير من عجائب
الدنيا السبع
طيب سهام قبل اطلاق رؤيه العلا ربما كثير
من الناس لم يكونوا يعرفوا ما هي العلا
اين تقع العلا بالضبط ولم يزورها كثيرون
ومنذ ان اعلنت الرؤيا حصلت همم كورونا
وبعد ان حصلت كورونا يعني كان هناك حركه
خفيفه بالنسبه للزوار سواء من داخل
المملكه او من خارج المملكه ولكن لاحظنا
منذ عامين ان وصلنا وحتى خلال هذه الفتره
خلال الفتره اقامتنا في هذا الوقت لاحظنا
بان هناك تغير كبير في المناطق حركه
السياح نشطه جدا من مختلف الجنسيات مثلا
نحن نقف عند صخره الفيل هذه صخره كما
تشاهدون قبل عامين التقط صوره انا هون يا
سهام هذه الصوره التقتها كان لا يوجد اي
شيء سوى صخره الفيل وايضا الصخور والجبال
المتواجده لكن اليوم صار في خلف هذه
الصخره مطاعم ومقاهي وكثير ايضا من
الاماكن الترفيهيه هنا في هذه المنطقه على
كل حال خلينا نتابع الان تقرير
الحجر والذي سنقدمه الان اذا الحجر هو اول
موقع تراثي سعودي صنف ضمن لائحه التراث
العالمي لليونسكو صباح العربيه كان هناك
نتابعه
[موسيقى]
هنا اول موقع سعودي صنف على لائحه يونسكو
للتراث العالمي عام 2008 الحجر يحمل بصمات
حضاره ومملكه الانباط التي نشات في
المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه لشبه الجزيره
العربيه نشاهد معكم مقابر اثريه منحوته
يدويا تحمل بصمات حضاره الانباط على مر
التاريخ
[موسيقى]
قصر الفريد الذي يعد معلما سياحيا هاما من
اشهر مقابر الحجر واكبرها والصور السياحيه
المرتبطه بها ويتميز بواجه ضخمه يلاحظ
فيها دقه وجماليه النحت هنا
[موسيقى]
كثرت الروايات والحكايات التي تحوم حول
قصر البنات هذه المقبره التي نشاهدها الان
يقال بان فتاه جمعتها علاقه حب مع احد
نحاتي مملكه الانباط فقتلها والدها هذا هو
قصر الملك
[موسيقى]
هنا ديوان موجود في اعلى نقطه هنا في
الحجر كبار الشخصيات والقاده في مملكه
الانباط كانوا يلتقون هنا في هذه المنطقه
الدينيه التي تحولت بعد الاسلام الى ممر
لقوافل الحجاج والتجاره
[موسيقى]
التي تعد اخر مركز لمخطط رحله عبر الزمن
المخطط الذي اطلقه ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان لتفعيل المواقع
التراثيه بقطار سياحي بطول 46 كيلومترا
يمر بالبلده القديمه ثم دادان ثم جبل عكمه
ثم الواحه النبطيه وصولا الى هنا الى
الحجر
[موسيقى]
دين يعني شكرا على تقديرك والحجر شكرت
مفاجاه للسياحه السعوديه بادراجها على
قائمه اليونسكو للتراث العالمي كاول موقع
تراثي السعودي حدثنا اكثر عن الحجر وانت
لزرتها الموقع
طيب سهام الحجر ادرج في عام 2008 كاول
موقع سعودي تراثي ضمن لائحه التراث
العالمي ليونسكو نحن ذهبنا الى الحجر
والذي يعتبر ايضا احد المعالم واحد عجائب
ايضا الموجوده هنا في العلا وعندما نتحدث
عن العجائب نتحدث اما عن عجائب بفعل
الطبيعه كما صخره الخلفي التي تشبه الفيل
او الماموث الضخم وايضا العجائب بفعل
الانسان سهام وايضا لكل المشاهدين عندما
ذهبنا امس الى الحجر يعني نحن نتحدث عن
الاف السنين نشاهد هذا النحت وهذه المقابر
الضخمه يعني هناك صخور كبيره على هيئه
جبال بداخلها مقابر عده كل جبل يحكي روايه
وقصه هناك جبل يحكي بان شخصا ما اراد ان
يتفرد بهذا الجبل وان يكون قبره فبالتالي
سمي به القصر الفريد وللمفارقه
هذا الشخص الذي اختار بان يدفن في هذا
القصر لم يدفن فيه فهذا القصر هو خالي حتى
الان واحنا عرضنا في هذا التقرير ايضا
تلاحظي وتتخيلي بانه انت موجوده في هذا
المكان الذي ادرج على لائحه التراث
العالمي لليونسكو تشعر بانه
اشخاص كانوا متواجدين قبل الاف السنين
ونتحدث قبل الميلاد سهام كانوا متواجدين
هنا عاشوا كيف كانوا يتفاعلون كيف كانوا
يتحدثون وكانوا يتواصلون وكان لديهم همم
ايمان بالحياه ما بعد الموت يعني هنا نشبه
بايضا بمثلا حياه الفراعنه كانوا يؤمنون
بحياتنا بعد الموت وبالتالي بنوا
الاهرامات مملكه الانباط التي نشات في شبه
الجزيره العربيه وتحديدا في المنطقه
الشماليه وعاصمتها كانت جنوب مملكه
الانباط كانت في الافلام كانوا يعتقدون
بانهم يريدون ان يكونوا ما بعد الموت في
مقابر كبيره وضخمه فعندما في الحجر ترين
اكثر من جبل او اكثر من قصر كل قصر له قصه
له حكايه وهذه القصور هي عباره عن المقابر
على فكره نحن اقتربنا كثيرا من هذه الجبال
ولكن لا تستطيعين يعني ان تدخلي من داخل
المقبره وكنا تجولنا
يعني انت محظوظه لانك في منطقه عمرها اكثر
من 200,000 عام يعني توصف منطقه الحجره
انها متحف يعني صخور لمقابر منحوته على
الصخور في الهواء الطلق الم تخافي من دخول
الى هذه المنطقه دين
والله انا امبارح كنت عمالي بحكي للزملاء
انه خفت لانه شوي دخلت لجوا كثير داخل
بعرفك مغامره ناديه اطلع لازم اطلع لبعد
بس بس كمان انا بدي احكي لك انه هذه
المنطقه يعني لما كنا نروح على الحجر كمان
بتشوفي من خلال الجبال في وجوه كمان غريبه
يعني احنا كمان صورنا صوره شفنا عباره عن
جبل ومتل وجه انسان موجود في هذه المنطقه
وكمان في قصه كمان انا حكيتها بالتقرير بس
نرجع ناكد عليها انه في كان كانت فتاه
عاشت قصه حب في مملكه الانباط مع احد
النحاتين ولكن والدها غضب جدا يا سهام
فقتلها وبالتالي شيد هذا القصر يسموه قصر
البنات يعني كانت هذه احلى الروايات
والاساطير التي حكت في هذه المنطقه تعتبر
هذه المنطقه المنطقه الجذب للمبدعين منذ
200000 شكرا نعود اليك نادين بعد قليل من
العلم نورتها
[موسيقى]